our a reddit discussion forum now has
nearly 5,000 of our viewers and
listeners there I was on the reddit
discussion forum this morning some
really interesting discussions there you
can find that at david pakman.com slash
read it and I wanted to point out just a
couple of these for you that I found
pretty interesting first and foremost a
discussion about whether the Democratic
Party should drop gun control from their
platform and it's a post that kind of
reflects a discussion we had a little
bit with Bill share a month or two ago
which is that it may not be advantageous
for Democrats to run on gun control or
what I call gun safety regulations
partially because it seems that there's
not going to be much movement on that
even after the Sandy Hook shooting with
something like 90% support in the public
for full background checks president
obama still wasn't able to get that
passed so if it can only hurt you and
it's unlikely that we are going to see
movement maybe democrats should step
away from running on gun control another
idea from the david pakman show read a
discussion forum what about banning
private banking banning private banking
there is a very interesting discussion
about this and a really good case made
of course it would never ever ever
happen given how much control the
banking industry has over our elected
officials Democrat and Republican alike
but an interesting discussion
nonetheless an interesting post with a
link to an interview of white separatist
white nationalist Richard Spencer by an
an African British reporter very
interesting interview and I encourage
you to participate in that discussion
which a lot of people are finding very
interesting comparing and contrasting my
interview approach when I interviewed
Richard Spencer to that of this British
reporters and it's a very interesting
interview I encourage you to check that
out and then a nice little post asking
whether David Pakman is oddly soothing a
poster at david pakman.com slash read it
pointed out that my coverage of the
horrible Texas shooting story while
wearing my hair in that crazy wacky way
that I did
was soothing in some way so hey listen I
appreciate it anyway that I can soothe
or relax the audience I will III
appreciate including boring people so
much that they listen to the show in
order to fall asleep yeah I haven't
gotten one of those emails lately but I
used to get them all the time maybe
maybe I'm more agitated now in the Trump
era so I just don't don't have as
relaxing of a cadence or something like
that I don't know
anyway I invite you to join the reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t